it's fun we just got hassled by the lapd
on the way to the studio two cops pulled
us over an asian guy and a bold guy
and uh we had inched over the line what
was it the line of the the traffic line
the uh intersection now by the way he
he was next to us the cops and we pulled
up to where he was and then he pulled up
so i kind of thought i could pull up
because i figured that well he's pulling
up i guess i can pull up but
you know what he's basically saying is
we're pulling up because for our own
safety we don't like people next to us
because we think you could take shots at
us or whatever which again you know and
we weren't planning to do
but i didn't realize that that i know
it's bad out there but i didn't realize
i didn't think he was like oh
they're gonna shoot us in the head
so we'll go up
so he moved up i moved up and then he
looked it up he looked at me
and do you remember the first thing he
said i don't really remember is it sir
why did you roll through the line there
have you been drinking tonight yeah you
guys are drinking tonight i'm like first
of all the light is green i'm like right
it's a green light so i'm i'm going
through the green light
okay
that's uh how it works
and he's like well i'm going to pull you
over to do a dewey check and i'm like
i had exhibited no behavior of drinking
i was not swerving
there was no smell of marijuana or
alcohol in the car
um you know there was nothing going on
we're on our way to the studio
every time i defend the cops by the way
and when i say i defend the cops i just
defend the idea that there needs to be a
police force
i don't really defend the cops per se
i just defend the idea that you need to
have
some enforcement of the law or rich
people just hire mercenaries
um
and then chaos
ensues
but every time i even try to defend that
you know you you have interactions with
these people and they're always bad
and they're always like kind of abusive
and i'm a white guy
in a nice car imagine if i was a black
guy what they could get away with doing
they bait you
into saying something disrespectful so
that they can bring you in he kept
threatening me with other first of all
we pull over okay
and you could tell he's mentally
unstable many of the people in the lapd
are mentally unstable okay this is not
their first choice of employment
he identified himself as a dre
what was it again a drug recognition
expert a drug recognition expert he's an
expert on recognizing when people are on
drugs
because apparently that's hard
to do
it's an art it's a science
because you would never know when
someone's on drugs unless you had a drug
recognition
expert
so lucky
so now this drug recognition expert
based on the fact that i was not
swerving not slurring
no smell of alcohol or marijuana
but i was answering his questions
coherently he was like oh he must be
[ __ ] up
so he he pulls me over and then he
starts going at me
he goes if he had a drink i said not in
13 years which is true
and he goes okay
and then i'm like
he goes well we're gonna do a test here
uh and he pulls out a pen
and he goes what color is the pen no
it's a clear pen
it's a clear pen that looks bluish
purplish kind of
it's a weird tint it's a bic pen
i got i don't know blue clear he's like
oh he thinks he's got someone
like dummy first of all it's not even a
sobriety test the sobriety test you get
me out of the car
this is like a waste of both of our time
you just want to bait me into saying
something crazy you could bring me in
and then you don't have to do your job
for the rest of the night
i get it
so this emotionally unstable lunatic
uh then has me follow the pen cap with
my eyes he's like don't move your head
just your eyes which i can do i go to
the left you know right left right we
get it
i complete that
and he goes um
you know he's kind of a dick he's being
a dick
and
i go to rental
here's the insurance
i've not had a drink in 12 years we're
going to work
he's being a dick so then he's more of a
dick starts lecturing me about dewy's
and
you know whatever and this is my job and
i'm like okay but i passed we're done
so then as he's leaving i go scumbag to
ben because i was yelling at ben
but here's the deal with them you can't
say to their face they'll put you in
jail but what you do is you say to
someone in the car something about them
because that's freedom of speech but if
you say it to them they will say that
you are being
uh
uh whatever menacing threatening or that
you are uh out you know because he's
like he alluded to the fact that he
could take me in for multiple tests uh
he goes here's that's only one test
there's many tests so what he's
basically saying is say the wrong thing
i'll bring you in you'll pee in a cup
we'll do blood whatever it is you know
which then i call a million lawyers and
we go to war with piggy blue collar
piggy pig
but
we don't want to do that you know what i
mean we don't want to do that okay
but
uh he's uh you know drunk on his own
power uh a uh not the brightest bulb
um you know he's on on dewey enforcement
in beverly hills right
um
and then he comes back he goes what was
that i was like oh i didn't see anything
i said i have freedom of speech it's my
own car i can say whatever i want he
goes well what did you say i said it's
none of your concern and then we just
start fighting like going at it for what
about 20 minutes 20 minutes about 20
minutes going back and forth with this
civil servant slob
about um you know why i have rights
that's all
about why i have rights and why this
idiot
uh doesn't get to just you know
uh and again this is the pandemic or
whatever it is it's going back to 911
it's like
this is instilled and i'm like i'm like
with the city falling apart with people
getting killed smashing grabs robberies
do you think the best use of your time
right now is to argue with a guy that
we've proven is sober and is not
breaking any laws
do you think that's the best use of your
time he's like well what do you do for a
living i said i'm gavin newsom's
personal assistant
that's exactly what i said
i said that's what i know
and we got back if i said i'm somewhat
well known i said i'm not crazy well
known compared to other people but
i'm decently well known because he goes
he said some [ __ ] about you have you
ever been shot at i'm like no i defend
cops
on large platforms i've said nice things
about cop i'm gonna take them all back
he's like have you ever met someone
who's been the victim of a dewey no
aren't they dead
isn't that your point
he's like do you know have you ever gone
to a dewey scene
no
is that something i'm even allowed to do
am i even allowed to just
go to dewey scenes
to look at mangled people
to learn
i'm not drinking
but again the cops are abusive and
belligerent they're trying to make you
say something they're trying to trip you
up it's incredibly unprofessional that
the way that they behave and act and
it's
sad but i was um
i you know argued my position pretty
well i said hey buddy like
you know at any time did you think i was
gonna go in
yeah i thought i thought we weren't
getting the episode in in time for sure
well no but did you think i was going to
jail no i didn't think you were going to
jail but i thought it might escalate a
little bit more but i did a good job i
held your ground i hope i got because
what the the thing is is they're so used
to just
trampling on people's civil liberties
and rights um
like for example
i'm not drunk we've proven i'm not drunk
i made a comment to my friend in the car
guess what it's none of your business
that i said you were a scumbag
if i say to your face i like people who
say things to my face i'm like because
you can bring him to jail that's what
you like liar
you're a liar
you you're you're a power crazed
psychopath you're the entire reason
we have [ __ ] problems right now in
this country because you people show up
somewhere and start firing wildly
because you're all insane
okay not all of you but far too many
let's be clear
far too many of you are [ __ ] out
there causing real problems he's an
asian guy he's like he said i was racist
and they were spitting on me and i
didn't take them to jail i'm like number
one you probably did number two
i'm not spitting on you i'm telling you
uh that i have a right
as a human being i'm sorry that uh
doesn't sit well with you
but when i said gavin newsom's personal
assistant the bald guy laughed yeah the
other cop on the other side yeah
baldy laughed but yeah i mean you know
what are you gonna do this is why the
lapd i mean they're the most corrupt
police force in the country so they
don't do much but whatever they do is
always bad like whatever they get
involved with is uh horrendous